we have an exciting update to share with
you this morning earlier this month we
told you about the dramatic rise in
online pet scams over the course of the
pandemic
including one woman in particular who
lost twenty four hundred dollars while
trying to buy
a puppy well one viewer with a little
pup
was so moved by her story that she did
something quite remarkable our consumer
investigative correspondent anna werner
has more just something to start yet
with
so this is what jeannie dixon of spokane
washington had been hoping for
a newfoundland puppy to ease the pain of
losing her 19 year old daughter charlene
last year charlene was going to change
the world
but earlier this month she told us she'd
been scammed
sending over twenty four hundred dollars
to the operators of this website
for a puppy named ben only to lose it
all
i blamed myself because it was a stupid
thing to do
the bbb says online scammers have stolen
more than 2.8 million dollars from
americans this year
for pets never received but in this case
i saw your guys's article local breeder
becky deakins saw our story on facebook
it just made my heart ache reading it it
was just horrible
she decided to give one of her
newfoundland puppies to dixon
and with help from cbs spokane affiliate
krem
reached out to her with the way that
2020 has been and the world is right now
i felt like we needed something good
to come out of this and so i just knew
that that was going to be the right
thing to do
and for jeannie dixon it's completely
overwhelming that people gave me grace
for losing all that money for a dog but
like i told her
charlene was going to change the world
and she just changed the world
for me because of this article she named
the puppy
maggie for cbs this morning i'm anna
werner
as a very cute dog now the puppy would
normally cost about twenty five hundred
dollars and the breeder says
that's the cost of the puppy normally
about the same amount of money that
dixon lost
so all's well that ends well thank you
breeder becky deakins that's so lovely
to do those new fees are really
wonderful wonderful dogs and just the
expression on her face
she's holding maggie yeah really nice
maggie's a sweetie
some days you do this job and you have
to go ah
there are good people in the world
there's a lot of good people out there